In this video I would like to exercise
finding the face of the surface of a body
by decomposing its main parts into so-called unwrapping.
One way to achieve this is
imagine that the given body
is made of cardboard.
Imagine we're cutting
right where I paint,
and also here,
and here; also here.
and back where it is not visible at the moment.
The body will unfold in shape,
similar to what I paint.
When we unfold this body,
we see it much easier
to understand how his face is.
The face of the given body
is the sum of the persons
of its constituent elements.
Well, let's decide where to start.
How much is the surface of this body that I mark?
If we look at the run,
this body responds to that person.
We see that this is a triangle
with base 12 and height 8.
So the face will be equal
1/2 of the base, which is 12, 8, that is, the height.
This is the same as 6, multiplied by 8,
which is equal to 48 square units,
depending on what square units are used.
The same is the face of the second triangle of the stroke.
We can not see the second triangle of the picture,
which I drew,
but if it was transparent,
this would be this triangle,
also equal to 48 square units.
Now we can find the face of -
let's call them the side panels.
This is a side panel
with a height of 14 and a width of 10,
and here is the second side panel.
We see that this height is the same
like the panel on the right - 14.
This panel is the same as this one,
and the other is from the country we do not see.
The face of each of these panels
will be 14 by 10 = 140 square units.
And finally we have to find the face of the base.
This is the area here that I color.
Here's that face.
The face will be the height multiplied by the width,
or 12, multiplied by 14.
If we multiply this in mind, it will be equal to
12 by 12 = 144, plus 12 by 4 = 24,
there is a total of 168.
Therefore, the total area
will be equal to
48 + 48,
which is 96,
plus two side panels,
the sum of the persons of which is 280.
We write the number below 96
and we remain the foundation,
which is 168.
I want to write it in the same color.
168.
And by gathering these three numbers,
we get the face on the surface of the whole body.
I think it's very useful to unroll the body
and to form this crawl,
to have a visual idea of
all components.
6 + 0 + 8 = 14
We carry one in mind,
we get 1 + 9 equals 10,
plus 8 is 18, plus 6 is 24; we record 4,
transfer 4 and collect 2 + 1,
we get 5.
So the face of the surface of the whole body is
544 square units.